[Music]
i believe
his top aide had accidentally told the
truth
of the cover-up that they purposely hid
life-and-death information from the
department of justice in fear
that that information could be
weaponized against them
everything is unraveling and he's shaken
and he's trying to rope everyone in
including the senate including the
assembly as many
elected officials as possible instead of
telling the truth to the 15
000 families who lost loved ones in the
last 10 months in this
in our nursing home facilities that new
york democrat assemblyman who claimed
governor cuomo threatened to destroy him
for criticizing his nursing home
response
says he won't be supporting the governor
politically anymore
as backlash over the crisis grows
new york gop congressman tom reed joins
us now to react congressman thanks for
being with us this morning
so that assessment you just heard of
what cuomo is actually going through
do you think it's accurate do you think
he's shaken right now
what's actually going on behind the
scenes in your opinion well i applaud
rod
kim for stepping forward and i would
join him in the effort to hold the
governor accountable
to completion and it's exactly accurate
i think exactly what happened
is what he described on the cover-up his
number two cuomo's number two
went over uh admitted the truth you know
and she clearly fumbled in her execution
of trying to put this genie back into
the bottle when she went over to the
state assembly in state senate
and admitted on that tape confession of
criminal activity with obstruction of
justice pergary to the department of
justice
but i want to go further i still want to
demand accountability for why this
order that killed 15 000 people
that we are talking about where he
ordered positive 19
proven 19 patients back into nursing
homes where residents were not
uh infected ended up being the root
cause
of this thing that is going to need to
be further investigated
representative reid we've talked to you
in the past we've talked about what
accountability might mean what it might
look like
for governor cuomo whether or not that's
a repeal of his emergency powers
impeachment
whatever it might be i lived in new york
for some 14 years i can't tell you how
many people kick a can down the road and
complain
about bill de blasio or complain about
governor cuomo but you know what they do
in the end is they vote democratic is
there any electoral accountability i
know you
potentially have some interest in
challenging governor cuomo does a
republican have a shot
to unseat someone like governor cuomo
absolutely and we are seriously
considering it we've been been asked by
many people to do this for months
because i think they appreciate the way
i govern not the governing by
arrogance and bullying that governor
cuomo does but by trying to bring people
together as a proud republican
i go into the room with democrats i
founded the only bipartisan group in
washington dc the problem solvers caucus
i go into those fights knowing who i am
what i'm fighting for
and i gotta tell you up in albany one
party control under democratic control
people are getting sick of it i've been
in the bronx i've been in harlem
i've been inside the inner cities of new
york city and i will tell you they are
saying the extreme policies coming out
of
albany are killing their communities
they do not like
this one party control and i agree with
them and if i'm that voice
to take on the governor i will put my
work ethic i will
put on my republican ideology that i
believe in but i'm open to be challenged
and to inspire people
to do it better for new york and not be
afraid
of the different points of view that the
democrats bring to the room
that's what we'll be looking at as we go
to change one party control
in albany new york so representative
andrew cuomo
if he does run again if he survives this
to the ballot box would be running
for a record fourth term uh if
someone whoever is going to challenge
him needs to be formidable considering
the political machine that he's built
built as we've found out recently
through a lot of intimidation and now
cover-ups
when would we know if you're going to be
a candidate what's your timeline to
decide
and what would you run on this issue and
what would what would be the top two or
three issues you'd run up
look at the nursing home scandal is not
a political uh scandal from my
perspective
i've been fighting this for months
because 15 000 people died
when this order was issued on march 2 in
march 2020
we told the governor don't do this
you're going to kill thousands of people
we also had the nursing home association
within 24 hours
from the national organization tell them
you're going to kill people by doing
this
this is about holding accountable the
governor for this
reckless order that he did knowing he
was going to kill thousands of people
and then i watched his number two dr
zucker give a press conference this week
and double down on the lie that
political fact checkers said was
false that they were listening to
federal uh government officials from the
trump administration that
this is why they did what they did that
was ruled false months ago by the fact
checker
that type of lying that type of
arrogance and then
dr zucker had the arrogance to tell
those 15 000 people that
that died to their graves that they
would do it exactly the same way again
that type of arrogance has to end it is
real quick when are you going to make a
decision whether you're running or not
look we're going to get this taken care
of on the republican side we're going to
have a family discussion because we need
to be organized like i said it's gonna
be a formal effort
we're looking uh we gotta make this
decision sooner rather than later
so stay tuned we're in those final uh
positions in my
in my house because i have to obviously
talk to my family and have that final
okay but i will tell you we are getting
close because
yeah i can't stand it any longer this
state needs to come out of one party
control let us know what you do for sure
representative tom reed appreciate it
thank you thank you